this is friends forever yeah no no I
gave it I'm only using you for my fame
this is a kind of a segue setup this is
the Ice King in Vice
how do you say a vegan life-giving majus
life-giving Magus to his home to do
exactly that to give life to his lamp we
seem to have a real fondness for he like
really wide that lamp specifically alive
was I history before with the lamp I
can't know I don't remember anything he
did say and I'm trying to remember
exactly he said he told the lamp a lot
of Secrets though it seems it was has
the strong connection with the lamp lamp
seems different but kind of nice you
know is willing to chat with him and
stuff gets really selfish and wants even
more friends so forces like giving men
do giving man juice let's call a Master
Shake that's yeah that math magic magic
shake so you always said bring till I
have all these other friends and they're
all pretty much hipsters I just want to
talk about like philosophy what
everything means that we don't like you
but we'll hang with you that's very
hipster philosophy the way to my hipster
cuz we're talking about adventure time
and I'm getting all philosophical true I
don't wanna hang out with you and I hate
you but I'm hanging with you boys so
yeah that hat is pretty hipster you to
wear it forward though if you're a true
hipster you just look like something
from the late 90s no now you really look
like something for the late nineties you
look like that cool character it's
supposed to save a show from getting
canceled wait freeze oh wait no Zach
never actually like wore a hat I don't
think anyone they show did they you know
their hair is just too amazing to cover
up are you screeched it every once in a
while and I think that way why are we
talking about
oh oh my god what you see by the
all the rest of these adventuretime
felines are just gonna be talking about
other V logs we should be - I just want
to say one thing really quickly about
shame by the Bell when an Adult Swim
started showing some saved by the buyer
yeah they did a special bumper for the
whole I'm so excited thing but they
turned it into like this reverse metal
not metal sound but like looking metal
and slowed it down so it's it was so
freaking disturbing looking up it's
great that my scene is meant to be
disturbing so needed the slow-mo or
metal filter so yeah so he gets all his
friends and they don't trick they don't
you have good they don't treat them bad
and they just sort of like trying to
change him and say yeah they're just not
a fan of that so he freezes some kicks
them all out the window even even though
she's like kind of pleading for her life
and like his said what have I done wrong
whatever gets her out of the lamp yeah
and then badges shaking him are just
sort of leaning out the window and
wondering if they can be friends he says
no but he likes the book so they can be
friends with him I thought this one you
know this one remind me of what was that
episode where Finn has the smaller
versions of everybody oh no no we were
magic men yeah you know what I'm talking
about yeah yeah it might be a little bit
of that there's something like it feels
kinda like a social experiment a little
bit um and you know what for you to
bring these people to life these friends
first of all just one friend that's
perfectly fine but then you want more
you know and you just totally push the
one that kind of mattered out of the way
actually twice if you count magic shake
yeah so yeah cuz he just came on his own
where me vitam over here amy was happy
to be there he was happy to talk with
him he's like I want real friends and so
he makes this lamp that actually it
looks like an okay friend like doesn't
understand it as much
is fine and they just keeps going and
the friends I'm glad the friends aren't
just flat-out jerks like I said they're
kind of this interesting hybrid of like
you know kind of nice but kind of
douchey at the same time too it's like
you know they're fine hanging with him
as long as they change him yeah I think
remember they all they all know how all
of his secrets yeah there's that so and
they yeah we don't like you but we want
to that we're here for you yeah and yeah
sound weird interesting lines like that
I thought we're kind of cool and it's
it's not one where I was necessarily
watching it like ooh
this means that and this is a connection
to this it's just sort of more like this
abstract I guess wants a yesterday X
story it's a kind of is but um I just
sort of like the direction where it's er
it just kind of naturally flows to you
know it doesn't feel like hey we're
trying to say this you know it feels
like it just can't goes the direction
like if this weird thing happened and
this was the setup this is just what
would come of it you know like they
still kind of stay in character and I
mean I guess he's been addictive
günther iced cakes Benedict to him for a
long time so it kind of has it coming
but but yeah and I think even in the
same sentence he calls him Gunther and
then Gunther was yeah it was funny but
no I liked it I liked Yen I serve like
that you know like both kids and adults
can kind of watch and not get the exact
message or someone can find something
like a little deeper that might be a
little different for each person like
they can sort of take something a little
different from it but ya know I like
that I thought there was just enough
stuff that was opened up for like hey
you can interpret this way but then
there's also some stuff that most likely
will give you this feeling or this idea
or whatever so I definitely liked it do
you think anything Master Shake is and I
love Dana saner I think he's great
well he was so nice in this episode too
he's some rarely place the nice guy
that doesn't he know it's kind of all
over the place depending on what he's in
okay I mean everyone knows him mainly as
Master Shake OU's an asshole yeah but
like these other parts that aren't so
bad he plays a jerk in home movies he
played Oh what else my thing is he
played a jerk on this a few times no
badges oh he play like okay but no um
anything he said I always like I just
he's got a very distinct voice and I I
think he's great
somebody uh I think on home movies they
were talking on the commentary and they
said his voice is kind of like an
acquired taste
you know because some people can't
listen to it it really not like it and
the way they put it I thought was a
great way putting it is just constantly
ask yourself why would anyone talk the
way he talks and enunciate and emphasize
the way he enunciates it emphasize like
nobody talks the way he talks you know
it's such a strange I mean actually this
one he kept talks normal in a lot of our
stuff that he does there is this very
strange way he emphasizes you know like
put the emphasis on these weird words
you know Cal like this where Walken does
and yeah I i SPECT he's good at doing
the normal stuff like this too for you
know being this weird matches character
but yeah um but yeah I like the way does
the really out there crazy yeah
what still want you we're watching the
hell one Joey that's right five of those
your your your ass your face is going
down your ass
it's like your ass is going into
live-action one it takes place in hell
and the character goes to visit his old
roommate which is played by dana snyder
and it's interesting to see him live
action yeah so you think I don't know
something like I mean kind of not it's
pretty neat
I'm sorry just another just again dana
snyder i love the guy um what i found
interesting about it was the whole i
it's almost like a forewarning of be
careful who your friends are don't be
friends with people just to be friends
with people you know cuz icing just
wants to be friends with whoever you
should be friends with people who want
to be friends
with you in a sense like the lamp and
magic I'll comb your pretty face is
going to help - yeah that's the show I
haven't seen it but apparently it's
really good it's fun uh life-giving
Magus and the lineup are kind of like
yeah I want to be your friend I'm okay
with this but it wasn't good enough
mmm so he wanted to be friends he wanted
more friends but he kept trying to force
himself on these people who didn't want
to be friends with him and then the end
it kind of backfired and it hurt him in
the end and he was kind of you know EADS
it says just be friends with people who
want to be friends with you don't try to
force friendship on people who don't
want to be around you and even some
people that want to be friends with you
it's like wow make sure you want to be
friends with them yeah like it's a it's
a two-way street you know and that's
kind of what I got from it plus Gunther
I'm so sad because I don't have my phone
case anymore
oh the Gunther yeah okay I upgraded my
phone and it's like all oh that's it
that's all I got I like you know that
was fun um especially the sweeping part
where I think Ice King comes out and
there's the Gunther's everywhere doing
all this crazy crap oh my god
you just see him in a pile on the floor
um yeah that reminds me like classic
like Bugs Bunny or whatnot just along
those lines there is a you know the
animation on this one seemed a little
different than usual it almost seemed
like they were like the mouths were a
little bigger and rounder and stuff like
usually when the Ice King talks it's
like his mouth is normal proportion to
his body here it looks like it took over
like just half of his body when he told
me I was like really really big and I'm
sure that's whatever an animation
company or a style of director whatever
but it was something where it's like cuz
most of these shows especially with such
a simple style they're pretty good and
you know mixing the animation you would
yeah we did what every once a while one
comes to rhyme just like that's a very
distinct style they're doing right now
you know whatever better or worse but
yeah
actually speaking of that I was hoping I
wouldn't forget I did the symbol the
high hat uh when he came up when he was
talking it was only briefly it reminded
me of a Canadian from South Park oh yeah
yeah and that's really what about your
head quote-unquote I like the fact that
you did doodle yeah every time to talk
to ya that really reminded me of our
Terrance and Phillip I'm wondering if it
was intentional or if it was just kind
of like well he's a high hat that's how
I had would talk if the other characters
didn't have dot eyes I would be like
that's totally intentional but because
they do it proudly is yeah my guess is
it's bright attention but I'm sure like
when they saw it don't think oh it looks
like yeah Phillip okay let's let's just
say it's a no much I'm sure they love
this show well so yeah I have really
remind me of that too so yeah no good
stuff a good episode friends actually
that is the song that they son can say
by the belt a bit friends forever
holy crap brands gonna be free